this episode of the minimalists is 100%
advertisement free so if you'd like to
support this podcast just visit the
minimalists comm slash donate we hope
you enjoy the show every little thing
you think that's me every little thing
you think that you need every little
thing that's just feeding your greed oh
i bet that you'll be fine without me
hello everybody this is Joshua fields
Millburn and I'm by myself right now but
don't worry Ryan will be here in a
moment we wanted to give you a special
quickie episode of the minimalists
podcast so this is episode number five
and we're calling this one priorities
and let's see a few weeks ago we
recorded episode number three and it was
about children but what most of you
don't know is that was our second take
of that episode we just weren't very
happy with the way the original episode
turned out and we would never want you
two to get a subpar episode of the
minimalists but at the beginning of it
we had this really interesting riff
about priorities and it was
unintentional but Ryan I just said this
this great conversation about priorities
and because we got a phone call recently
about about priorities we wanted to
share that with you so this will be a
bit of a quickie episode and you'll get
our thoughts on how you prioritize a
more intentional life but first I'd love
to give you some updates not an
advertisement by any stretch but but
certainly some updates on we have so
much exciting stuff going on this year
and it all culminates in sort of this
film we have coming out so if you don't
want to know what's exciting and what's
going on in my life or Ryan's life then
you might want to fast-forward a little
bit because we're just going to give you
a few updates really quickly first off
Ryan and I just got back from Saint
Petersburg
Horta and it was an amazing trip we
helped our friends open a coffee shop in
Saint Petersburg called bandit and I'll
tell you before they opened up that
coffee shop it was a bit of a coffee
desert and we're going to talk to you a
lot more about that coffee shop in the
future because the exciting news we have
is we recently became partners in that
business with them so we will be
spending a lot more time in Saint
Petersburg in the coming months and
years helping them out with that
business but I'm so proud of what Joshua
Weaver and Sara Weaver and Chris
Costanza have done to open that shop
they have done they just created this
beautiful space that is very well
curated very intentional and they're
really passionate about what they're
doing and while we were down there we
did a documentary screening of our our
film minimalism which will be in
theaters in May but that screening was a
special charity screening because Ryan
and I are right now trying to build this
orphanage in Honduras with our friends
from a charity called the hope effect
and we're getting really close to our
goal and actually win this this episode
posts well it would be the last day that
you can contribute to that to that
campaign so if you want to help us build
that orphanage you can just go to the
minimalists dot-com slash hope and you
can find all out all about the entire
thing so everything we did down in
Florida recently we also worked in the
coffee shop for two days a hundred
percent of our tips are going to that
that orphanage as well so thank you to
everyone who came out and participated
we had a sold out screening and we had a
line out the door all day Sunday our
first day open and I just wanted to say
thank you so much for everyone who
contributed and in some way which
actually leads me to what we're doing
with this documentary so the documentary
which is called minimalism a documentary
about the important things it hits
theaters in the US and Canada on may
24th 2016 and man we are so excited so
we started filming this thing like at
the end of of 2013
and we've spent more than two years
curating this thing we went out and we
interviewed neuroscientists and
musicians and artists and minimalist
families and architects and people who
live in tiny homes and psychologists and
psychotherapists like all of these
different people who had all these
different perspectives on more
intentional living on simple living on
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less stuff and so we interviewed
all these people and our director who is
phenomenal his name is Matt dia Vela he
has helped us make the most amazing film
and we're so grateful and so excited to
finally bring it out there to you on May
24th but before it hits theaters Ryan
and I are going to hit the road and
we're going to 14 cities we just
announced the tour this week and a lot
of those tickets are selling out fast so
if you want to see us and the film and
we're going to host a special live
hashtag ask the minimalist version of
our podcast at each of these events you
can go to the minimalists comm slash
tour and you can find out about that all
14 events and and see if we're coming to
a city close to you if we're not coming
to a city close to you I have good news
for you you can still request a
screening of our documentary in your
city we already have dozens and dozens
of screenings all over the country that
are already planned but if there isn't a
screening near you that's okay you can
request your own screen and you can find
all the details about requesting your
own screening over at minimalism
film.com slash watch we have a lot of
people who are really excited about
seeing this and so we're going to get
this in as many communities as possible
and then after the US release we're also
planning a Canadian release as well as
an Australian theatrical release and
after that if you're not in the US
Canada or Australia don't worry we are
looking for distribution overseas some
of the walls make it
kind of complex the film lols and other
countries but we're working really hard
to bring this film to you so whether
that's going to be in a local theater
near you or it's going to be in our via
online it's really going to it's going
to find its way to you eventually so
stay tuned to that we'll have all the
information at the minimalists com
and of course every Tuesday the last
couple months we've done something
called Tuesdays with the minimalists and
you can ask us questions live every
single Tuesday on Twitter and periscope
if you want to join in there you can
find us every Tuesday 7:00 p.m. Eastern
on Twitter and periscope and finally I
have a workshop a writing workshop so
most of you probably know that I teach
an online writing class it's a I call it
a semester but really you can do it in
four weeks if you're really diligent but
I understand the a that is cost
prohibitive for many people and also
it's time prohibitive for many people
they just don't have the time to invest
and so I'm doing a one day workshop on
February 7th and I originally wanted to
make this a free workshop but I had
ended up charging 20 bucks for it
because we had to pay for the the
webinar software and also my adjunct
professor Sean mihalick is helping me
out with a lot of the details and I want
to make sure that he got compensated as
well so it's 20 bucks if you can't
afford that I totally understand don't
worry you can you can email Sean and
we'll see if we can get you a special
one-day scholarship so you can find all
the details at how to write better org I
also have a bunch of write free writing
resources there whether it's the the
daily writing tips on Facebook and
Twitter we have a really great
newsletter at how to write better org as
well that's all I've got for you right
now a lot of exciting stuff going on I'm
so looking forward to sharing this film
with you and if you have a question for
our podcast or a regular episode of this
podcast of course you can give us a call
406 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 we have a bunch of
awesome questions we're getting ready to
answer in the coming weeks
and you can also ask those questions on
Facebook or Twitter or Instagram just
use the hashtag ask the minimalists hey
guys this is Joan L Shaw from Oak Park
Illinois and I had a few questions the
first it is when you speak about
eliminating access what are your cues to
recognize when you've gone too far
the other is when I'm investing my time
and cash and causes that I love and I
find value in I tend to over commit so
do you have any suggestions on
minimizing schedules and duties how
would you politely say no how can I
avoid finding myself spread too thin
today's conversation is about priorities
and it's a very weird word we've talked
about this briefly in the past but until
so there's a book through the book by
Gregory McEwen called essentialism it's
a business book and and this is where I
learned this from but he he talked about
there are a bunch of ways to talk about
what we focus on and and one of the
things that we do is we talk about what
our priorities are and the extreme
example is the United Nations has a list
of their I think it's something like a
hundred and sixty three priorities it's
about five more priorities than I have
you know I you know I think that that we
use this word priority to mean like this
is what's important to me but when you
have 163 priorities what that really
tells me is that you don't have any
priorities at all in fact this word
priority was never used other than a a
singular word priority until the 20th
century yeah it's such a it's a word
that we just like throw around like
these are my priorities
yeah those my priorities my well and
that's a weird thing too because then we
give lip service to these priorities
right and and we say like this is
important I mean can you think about
when when you were working back in and
the core
world and we gave lip service to so many
thing one of my biggest priorities was
my health but yet I was eating fast food
every single day if not every single day
every other day oh and instead of going
to the gym after work I was going to
happy hour and racking up big bar tabs
but yeah offal is right up there with my
priorities for sure you had Coors Light
right right right elephant I drink Light
beer so that made it a little bit
healthier
it's fine yeah no I it's it's crazy
because we say that we have priorities
we say that the people closest to us
really matter that we love them we say
that we want to focus on what we're
passionate about for me my priority what
I said was the priority was writing I'd
always wanted to write and write fiction
in particular and and so I spent most of
my 20s as an aspiring writer which
really just meant that I aspired a lot
but didn't do a whole lot of writing I
aspired all over the freaking place but
I didn't get anything written and that's
because when something is difficult we
tend to move on to the next thing and we
get so stuck in our ways and we we say
you know what I am a writer in my head
but I'm not actually a writer by by
practice and I think there's so many
things we want to do so many things we
want to make a priority yeah but our
priorities are really how we spend our
days it's what we do it's yeah how we
spend our time and so you know it's
funny I'll catch myself now if I get on
to our last episode was about about
technology and social media and you know
I'm certainly far from perfect and I'll
get on to Instagram and get lost in that
that sea of photos and in double-tapping
photos and stuff like that and in fact
sometimes I just remove it from my phone
altogether because I have to and and the
founder of of Instagram said it was
visual crack that's why it and that they
totally zag missions yeah and so that
crack that metaphorically or or
literally and for someone who the drug
addicts a great description become
there becomes a priority yeah yeah and I
I think the way to get around that is to
figure out what our actual priorities
are and then reallocate our time and
schedule our time toward the things that
we find meaningful in life and so
instead of aspiring to write as I did
most of my 20s I would do it haphazardly
it's been a few hours here I get really
excited about an idea for a week but
then I wouldn't actually put in the time
to do it
eventually had to find the time and I
was working 80 hours a week as as you
know I didn't have time to write well I
just instead of getting up at 5:45 a.m.
I started getting up at 4:45 a.m. I
wrote for an hour every single morning
this is probably a question that one of
our readers has I know it's a question
that I have so when you started to get
up at 4:30 a.m. yeah
what was the emotional leverage how did
you how did you flip that switch yeah I
think it ultimately has to do with pain
or or pleasure right I mean I had
previously associated pain with getting
up an hour earlier because I need that
extra hour of sleep and of course it's
painful to get up earlier and be tired
and I don't necessarily advocate getting
less sleep I think sleep is very
important for your health and we can
certainly talk about that but for me I
needed to find that extra hour and so
having enough pain associated with not
this lack of sleep but the lack of
writing the lack of doing what I wanted
to do the lack of cultivating something
that I was passionate about the lack of
not being able to call myself a writer
in earnest was more painful than that
extra hour of of sleep of missing that
extra hour of sleep and also ultimately
was about associating pleasure with the
activity itself writing for me was I
mean at the very beginning 80% of it and
I'm sure you're going through this now
because a book you're right in when I
was writing I want to put my head
through the wall 80% of the time it was
just like this exercise in drudgery
and I needed that though to get to the
other 20% which was the real the real
payoff
well eventually that that changes over
time as you get better and you get into
these patterns I don't know how much of
this you've you've found but I went from
80% being miserable to 70% being
miserable still about the 80/20 mark
yeah well I mean in overtime I
eventually got to where I was about
50/50 and it's never gotten better than
50/50 for me but I kind of realized
that's where I need to be is I need for
it to be this tedious mundane process
sometimes so that I can create something
that I can use to pan for gold as is the
metaphor that I tend to use is finding a
place that there's a bunch of sediment
and rock and garbage there but then
there's actually some gold in it as well
and that's that's the beauty that's that
that's the payoff but making that a
priority was just so difficult for me at
first until I realized that I needed to
associate enough pain with not doing it
and enough pleasure with the result I
would get furthermore I needed to to
check what my actual priorities were
like I was incessantly checking email
all day from the moment I woke up until
the moment my head hit the pillow my
blackberry blackberry at the time was
just on all day and there was really no
way for me to avoid that because I had
conditioned myself to not avoid it so my
real priority was incessantly checking
email it was getting on Facebook it was
pacifying myself that extra hour I had
at the end of the day with with
television but then I forsook all the
things that were actually important and
so figured out what my priorities were
was first figuring out what what do I
want to make a priority right and then
how do I spend my time right now yeah I
think you brought up a really good point
earlier when you were talking about
Instagram how sometimes you get into
those habits you get into the social
media
Oh triangles and all of a sudden this
has become your priority without you
even realizing it sure and just to and
consistently do something off of impulse
and not to check ourselves like that to
ask ourselves like okay as I'm sitting
here pacifying myself and I still do
this today like as I'm sitting or
pacifying myself is there anything else
that I need to work on right now is
there anything else I should be
replacing this activity with that I have
committed to myself to do and I would
say to that the commitment part that is
the that's the hardest part to any to
making any priority or priority just
like with you getting up at 4:30
committing to that with me changing my
diet getting to the gym three to five
times a week I've successfully
successfully been able to do that 50 out
of 52 weeks last year but but it was it
was all about making that my priority
and getting started and I will say that
what do they say 21 days the bill to
have it or and yeah I'll say you know it
didn't even take me 21 days really to
see the benefits of getting to the gym
regularly but yeah getting started is
definitely the hardest part but the the
commitment is definitely the most
important part when I'm stuck in it too
so if I I do have using that same
analogy there with Instagram the same
example rather with Instagram we were
out during Christmas time we were in
Minneapolis talking to Patric Verrone
we were filming that that last interview
for the theatrical release of our
documentary and Patrick said something
that was really valuable to me and I've
asked this question but not in the same
way by the way Patrick wrote a book
called enough and he talks about you
know what is enough in our lives and one
of one of the things that he asks is is
this where this belongs and man if I'm
asking that question about going through
your Instagram or or getting on to my
email like even even if I get on to my
email if I did it right now wouldn't
belong
here right I'm trying to do have this
conversation with you we're trying to
record a podcast if I'm sitting over
here checking email something doesn't
belong and that's obvious in a situation
like this right but I think we see it
all the time now with these you go to
Chipotle or something and and where
you're standing in line and you're the
only person who isn't buried in their
phone unless you are buried in your
phone then you don't realize it like me
sometimes I will look up from my screen
and I'll say wait a minute what does
this belong is this where this belongs
and sometimes it's yes maybe I really do
need to respond to someone while I'm
waiting in line but do I really is this
where this belongs and so maybe that's a
good question for us to ask ourselves
when we're trying to figure out what our
priorities are and I think our
priorities are ever shifting right I
mean last year recording a podcast was
not our priority we talked about doing
it but it was only after you have so
many people kept tweeting or sending us
postcards or whatever saying what are
you guys gonna start a podcast and and
then you know now we're getting people
say I've never listened the podcast
before but I'm listening to yours and
and we knew that this would be a vehicle
for us to add value to other people's
lives and because you and I both find so
much value and contribution I feel like
that this was right to make this a
priority but in order to make this a
priority something else has to be
removed from the table yeah that's a
really good point so our priority we
knew it would be a priority but my
question to you would be you know how
how can our listeners how can they
figure out not only what their
priorities are
but what priorities should they start
with because that I mean that's kind of
a conundrum in itself right like great
I've got health relationships
cultivating passions growing
contributing that's awesome right but
you can't focus on five things at once
you can't focus on 163 things at once it
just doesn't work that way unfortunately
totally totally
how are you able to to focus on on your
own writing how did you pick writing as
your priority to focus on first right
and so those five things you mentioned
health relationships passion growth
contribution after several years of sort
of having conversations like this we
decided okay these are our five values
these are the things that are sort of
the higher order values for us and it
was about picking one thing at a time
and and and slowly making progress on
that one thing yeah and I found that you
know it's it's just like when you get
good at juggling you can eventually add
you know an additional object into what
is your chainsaw right and so these are
the five chain souls if you like a
meaningful life thanks for listening
folks we'll see you soon every little
thing you think that's mean every little
thing you think that you need every
little thing that's just feeding your
greed oh I bet that you'll be fine
without every little thing that you got
ahead every little thing that you guys
you gotta reach forward
you got a grand oh I bet that you'll be
fine without me
so tear your eyes